and uh he is saying that uh with a win
here magnus has a 93 chance of
qualifying and here we go the game has
started the game has started we can't
quite see magnus carlsen yet but we see
his opening few moves and it's the
sicilian defense something that magnus
has been relying on ever since his world
championship match in 2018 against
fabiano caruana and uh here we go just a
very quiet line actually white not going
for the open sicilian instead bringing
his bishop out early white is the first
to castle black there just pushing a
pawn
and now we do see the first trade of the
game bishop takes knight that is a check
and black has doubled pawns but black
does have the bishop pair and a pawn
sacrifice early in the game level
naronian giving up a pawn in the middle
what do you think yeah this is actually
an idea that uh van forest played
recently he played this pawn sacrifice
so it's a new idea and i think he beat
prague with this e5 move and you get the
pawn up but look at black's pawns
they're just straggling there they're so
weak and uh it's a nice positional way
to play uh i've always thought white
should be doing okay here so it'd be
interesting to see what magnus's idea uh
on the black side of this is obviously
being very aware of that game by van
forest
yeah um as you mentioned van faris there
he was helping magnus in the world
championship match so yeah these top
players they sometimes they share ideas
sometimes
you see them employ the same idea with
white and then with black and uh right
now black is a pawn up but as you
mentioned ugly ugly pawns especially
those double pawns on the c file we came
up with a rhyme simon a couple of days
ago doubled pawns or troubled pawns and
those black pawns ugly
and
just looking at the database in front of
me i can see that magnus has else played
this particular position with the white
pieces
and
in an intriguing fact lavon aronian
played this particular position with the
white pieces against magnus carlsen in
the gold money asian rapid oh wow so a
sense of deja vu for the players and
levon won okay okay wow so levon
i mean that's good strategy right if
you've got good memories from a certain
position going for it again uh
makes a lot of sense and now magnus
there just bringing his queen out over
protecting his central pawns
it's gonna be a struggle maybe for black
to get castled if black ever brings his
knight out then maybe his central pawns
will be weak black still needs a few
moves to prepare getting his king to
safety in the meantime white i guess is
going to build up just bring a rook to
the center bring the white queen out
bring the white bishop out and some real
targets for the white pieces yeah i
guess one player i've seen who really
loves the bishop pair out of any world
champion is magnus carlsen i mean i know
you do as well david and probably you as
well ivanka i'm i'm a bit more of a
tricky knight kind of guy i love you
know throwing the knight about and
trying to trick my opponent but maybe
he's gone for this system because black
has the two bishops um but you know if
white can win a pawn back black is going
to be in a lot of trouble so you know
then there'll be no material
disadvantage and you can see after this
rook move that pawn on e5 in the center
of the board is starting to be targeted
so uh yeah i just i just wonder what
magnus is going to do here having a bad
score on this he's going to have some
kind of idea up his sleeve
yeah you mentioned these pawns being
targeted simon already black can't
develop his knight if he brings it out
this way the pawn in the center falls
protected by white's rook and if he
brings out the other way then a similar
trick can happen at the very least where
i can just take this knight and now it
is two knights versus two bishops but
once white regains his pawn in the
center black's just saddled with these
ugly pawns and some still these are
going to be targets long term the white
queen might come out attack this pawn
looks very pleasant for white so right
now i'm expecting to see magnus think
for a while about how to get this guy
into the game
maybe the best option is to just push
this pawn forward over guard in the
center and then develop the knight next
but uh this is a slow plan and in the
meantime white simply it's going to
develop and hit some weaknesses
and he's going to gain his pawn back at
some point right yeah well actually
looking at the database the main move
that black plays is actually to pick up
the first double pawn and push it one
square and just give it up completely
okay so this guy doomed long term um
it's very very weak it's going to be
targeted so giving it up right now
at least forcing white to take some
double pawns on
i've got to admit this to me still looks
very nice for white but
at least now black does have maybe some
uh pawn pushes in the center later in
the game this reminds me a game i had a
long time ago i know you mentioned the
seven deadly sins by jonathan rousen and
uh i had a very similar position to this
where i tried to get the pawn back and
jonathan with the white pieces beat me
in 20 moves so i'm getting some cold
sweats here looking at this position i
i'm not not a big fan of of the black
structure but that chess ball course is
such a great course i mean really should
be in every chess player's arsenal that
seven deadly sin book and course
yeah uh fully agreed and actually this
pawn structure reminds me of a game i
had against you uh in 2014 in the
british championships is it yeah
but uh that makes a change shall i say
it makes a big change probably the only
time i've beaten you i think so uh maybe
in classical chess um okay but i was
about to say in that game strategically
i felt i had promising chances but then
black's play is going to be dynamic
right that's what you managed to achieve
against me you managed to make it into a
mess get the bishops active
and things got really complicated and
magnus needs to try and do the same
he can't just sit and wait and allow
white pieces to come out and start going
for his weak pawns
um isn't it a bit surprising that he's
actually thinking here i know we said he
has to think but he's lost this position
before um
why is he thinking here i mean he's
either got an idea or he doesn't i think
it's because he believes in the
advantages of white's position because
like i mentioned earlier you know he
actually played this variation with the
white pieces himself
and it was played really recently in the
world blitz championship in warsaw
against boris gelfant but why would he
be thinking as black if he believes in
the
pluses behind white's position why would
he be playing this why would he go for
this
i i don't know especially because he's
gone for
this game and lost this very in this
variation before against lavonne in the
gold money agent i don't i don't quite
know but uh
here comes his answer
okay so we talked about the bishop pair
that bishop pair has gone black brought
his bishop out traded it off for a night
so material is level it's the same kind
of complement of pieces right now
but black has at least got rid of one
potential attacker of his pawns and
there we go magnus centralizing his rook
this looks strange to me to be honest
didn't look like the number one priority
to bring that rook to the center black's
king's still in the middle of the board
yeah i mean it still takes black two
moves to castle and uh as we mentioned
if white can just win one pawn back i
mean even something simple like uh
moving the bishop into the middle
targeting porn or moving a knight into
the middle uh i'd much rather be white
here white white smooths are so natural
to play and there's one thing about
having an advantage according to
computer and chess but there's another
thing about having an easier position to
play where you can just play normal
moves you don't have to think too much
and it seems like white has that
advantage at the moment of playing easy
moves here yeah and that's one thing
we've seen from levon especially it kind
of started halfway through last season's
tour but he loves to play instantly and
he loves these positions where the plan
is simple it's very straightforward he
can build momentum put pressure on his
opponent on the clock and i'm expecting
him to do that as you mentioned
very many tempting moves here for white
very natural tempting moves
it's hard to pick between them maybe
that's the only problem there are so
many too many good moves good moves
exactly yeah
this is the type of position in a long
game i would sit there for 30 minutes
deciding between two moves that are
probably just the same
just because they both look so good and
uh yeah i'm expecting white bishop
broadnight to move right now it's been a
little bit up and down for lavon in this
tournament the only player to beat diana
pognachi but
and he's also won a game against dingley
ren but also lost to artemyev and some
other players but he is a man on four
right ivanka judging by the grand prix
yeah i mean he had played an excellent
tournament in the
berlin grand prix and also i have to say
he's been in this type of position
countless times on the 20-21 season
and i can remember in skilling open it
it seemed like he needed a miracle
miracle performed so i mean somehow i
feel that this experience will kind of
will it will just basically favor him
and he was used to the pressure and he
said it himself he loves proving people
wrong
and uh you guys youtube both expected uh
lavon to develop the bishop of the night
which looked very very natural to me but
lavon has gone for a different approach
just uh
solidifying
that uh
pawn the double pawns there on c5 yeah
and just to show maybe why level iranian
has done this
we mentioned in this position white
bishop could come out and attack a pawn
white's knight could also attack this
weak guy which is pretty much
indefensible
for example bring the knight to the side
of the board or centralizing it to
target this pawn but then this idea
would happen black would push it forward
and white would be forced to take and
now white does have these double pawns
and
it's not clear whose pawn majority is
better black has a five versus three
advantage on the right half white has a
four versus two on the left half of the
board and that's why levano ronin pushed
this pawn forward i think the reason
both simon and myself were reluctant to
do this is because it does feel a bit
weak on this diagonal but if black
pushes the pawn white could just
recapture with his own pawn and he does
defend this knight
with his queen so black's bishop cannot
really take it um that is why magnus
just developed his knight and now levon
aronian has gone for this black pawn
that we mentioned from a different angle
so he's using his bishop but he hasn't
put it on a square where it blocks his
rook
very interesting play here and this guy
is going to be lost at some point now
does magnus push it forward and force
white to double his pawns by taking one
of these two ways or does black go on
the defensive and maybe to just bring
his knight back
but this feels slow and white tonight
will continue the attack of this pawn
and
one thing i've noticed like very strong
players um tend to do is avoid moves
like this knight d7 which is a very
passive defensive move trying to hold on
to your gains because okay knight d7
does defend the pawns but you have to
sit there and defend defend the defend
and um this looks like a much more
active and better try just throwing the
knight into the middle of the board uh
erodian obviously uh responds
immediately and he's going to get his
pawn back but at least magnus is now
trying to get a little bit of activity
here there might be some ideas of
pushing unleashing his bishop and maybe
the knight can even come over to to
target some of the white's pawns here so
i kind of like the way magnus has played
the last sort of couple of moves here
yeah we should issue a word of warning
here because it is possible for black to
get super greedy and try to grab the
white rook in the corner and uh by
playing this porn move that would be a
bad bad mistake because you give up all
your dark squares the computer does not
like this mobile by magnus yeah so just
to explain ivanka's point this would
give up the dark squares and would not
be favorable for uh magnus at all and if
we catch up with the game his last move
not approved by the computers um in this
position he's brought his knight to the
side he is attacking this pawn but
ivanka what might the reasoning be
behind this one i don't immediately see
why it's a blunder um he's attacking
this pawn if black captures the black
knight getting rid of the attacker then
at least black after the trade has
undoubled a set of pawns at this point
much less weak than it previously was
maybe the reasoning is because white can
just defend this pawn but how do you do
that you've got to be careful now if you
lift your rook up to defend this pawn
there will be this trick that we
highlighted earlier pushing forward
attacking this rook in the corner
from long range
maybe white can just step back with the
queen for example and defend the pawn
this way it's uh it's very shaky for
black this pawn is loose and this pawn
is the only defender of the black knight
if one of them falls black's position
might crumble
um yeah right now though it's still very
complicated let's
ignore the computer maybe for now but it
does look very promising for white if
levon is accurate i see uh philip on
the hashtag chesschamps on twitter
saying that magnus looks quite pale and
he did confirm to us yesterday that uh
he has been down with covet and he has
been feeling sick and even
hallucinating moves what is that all
about david yeah he's been missing
things very uncharacteristic for him
just
he mentioned yesterday in the interview
as soon as he starts to calculate that's
when the blunders actually happen
so he will be maybe relying on his
instincts more than ever today i mean he
has fantastic instincts he can kind of
play by hand but uh yeah when he starts
working out these long complicated
variations that's when the mistakes have
been happening
um i'm wondering i think maybe he just
looks pale because there's the lighting
in his room maybe he's got a window open
we need to figure
so
yeah i mean it takes you out of it
covered and he did play very bad
yesterday didn't get time so uh he's
obviously not his 100 normal self and
you also you told me
simon that you've been down with kovid
did it how did it affect you when it
came to chess if you played a little bit
of chess over christmas yeah i mean i
had it over christmas i mean i was
pretty much fine but i was extremely
tired and i couldn't play any chess i
normally play a lot of blitz chess but i
i was dropping pieces everywhere and
just could not think and they call it
the brain fog and it was more like the
brain just did not function at all for
me it was more than a fog so um yeah
it's strange how something like that can
just slow you down so much and uh
obviously magnus has a bit of that now
so uh i'm sure he'll be back to health
soon now he's he's uh he's a healthy
chap probably a bit healthier than me
you know
well you've been to the gym today simon
i did she's very good very good
yeah i need some inspiration from you
and the queen has retreated to the fan
they attacked porn and magnus playing
very quickly actually just uh pushing
that pawn forward and lavon ah tempo i
mean what was that wow
i'm saying he's not letting him think is
it he's just like bang straight away
yeah what do you make of that move david
as well that's that's getting crazy
already exactly it's not just that it's
a crazy move but to play it that quickly
uh i mean levon aronian he's the one
trusting his instincts now and it looks
like a pure pawn sacrifice by white but
some traps uh are in the position right
now and we have to show some of the
ideas here after black's pawn pushed
forward unleashing this bishop and
hitting the white rook in the corner
levon said okay i'm not letting you have
that rook i'm going to push my pawn
forward in the center and this pawn is
attacked three times this is the type of
invisible move i wouldn't even consider
but if black had taken with his own pawn
you lose the black knight if black takes
with the rook or with the bishop then
the white pawn steps forward with a
double attack winning a piece that is
really really sneaky by levon aronian
and magnus replying very quickly as well
just ignoring this pawn i think it was
poisoned but he instead fortifies this
black knight with his own pawn
wild position i've already got brain fog
here i mean i've just got brain fog at
the moment because it's all it's all
happening i mean a5 a move on the side
of the board when there's so much going
on in the center and
there's so many options available here i
mean white can give up the exchange
white can push the knight away uh it's
it's very complex i mean do you think
and this looks like a very sensible move
do you think lev his game plan against
magnus is trying to make it a bit
complicated knowing that magnus is under
the weather yeah i think you might be
right and knowing he needs a win as well
and uh talking of making things
complicated we continue to see
surprising moves here the black knight
is attacking the white rook levon didn't
even blink he did not consider anything
else he has sacrificed his rook he took
a pawn and now after knight takes rook
i'm expecting him to recapture and if we
do a quick material count here white is
down a rook for a knight and this knight
is temporarily offside but white does
have a lot of threats actually maybe
there are options this bishop might well
just skewer the black queen hit the
black rook behind it these black pawns
are incredibly weak this guy is going to
drop off this one is isolated this one
is isolated in the current position i
was about to well i did say that rook
takes knight was pretty much automatic
but there is also the option of the
bishop landing on this square hitting
the black queen immediately so levon
aronian not automatically recapturing
which most uh including myself maybe
would have done he is thinking of more
ambitious moves so he's a rook down
but is it basically just that
the magnus's pieces are so bad yep and
he will win something back he can grab
the knight back for now that's some
compensation but no he goes for the
black queen instead and the black queen
has to move either now or on the next
turn you could actually give up this
night this knight is gonna fall off
anyway you could flick in a check just
to ruin white's pawn structure around
the white king but i'm not sure whether
you even want to do that but if you move
the queen for example i'm just choosing
a random square then now white has a
choice do you take the knight do you
take the rook
everything's on the menu wow so
complicated already very complicated
yeah it's going to be an epic battle and
i think it's going to be
an absolutely incredible day of action
and we want you at home to be very much
part of all this also we would love it
if you tweeted us using the hashtag
chesschamps
or alternatively you can send us your
selfies remember in landscape mode and
we will feature them on the show
i've got a phone to pick with this just
so i was watching the show yesterday
yeah and i was like i'm gonna get myself
here
i was watching the whole show
i went to the toilet at that moment
of course
i didn't realize so i'm trying to get my
selfie on the show but you got it on did
you
oh i remember it yeah yeah you had david
in the picture oh my god yeah yes yeah
we even gave you a shout out simon you
missed
it
bad time to have a toilet break
and also i've noticed you've made a
couple of changes with the layout today
yeah and the evaluation bar did you make
it orange just for my beard yeah was
that just for me that's the of course it
was for you just for me yes yes yes
you know the whole thing just looks
better now right we have simon with the
orange bear we have the orange bar you
know just everything's just coming
together we have the orange squares
highlighting the last move on the board
yeah yeah it's all for you simon yeah
it's all for you i feel privileged now
i'll let you off then about uh yeah
this is where you belong i feel very
it's so nice to be back after nice to
have you back it really is off the world
championships and you know
the game's a slower pace but sitting
here yeah just it's lovely to be back
really is it's a whole day of talking
about chess and this exciting format as
well
yeah it's going to be good it's a lot of
fun yeah definitely talking of a lot of
fun this position i think we're having
fun analyzing it looking at it but the
players they must be super stressed
right now and magnus just trying to find
a safe square for the black queen and
it's not easy no matter where the black
queen goes there will be pluses and
minuses uh to the square it lands on and
uh yeah magnus burning time on the clock
both players now down to eight minutes
it's so complicated it's so messy and
there will in the end be an imbalance
whether that's on material pieces or
whether that's simply the pawn structure
if black can't emerge from this position
with extra material then i think he's
just going to lose the game black's
pawns are too weak so magnus needs to be
really really careful here the computer
the ginger bar 0.0 i mean come on
but i'm sure both the players don't
don't think that at the moment they're
just trying to find the best moves i
mean
i suppose you know continuing a line
that you could consider here you've got
to move the queen so
you know we talked about our game when
at least with a bad pawn structure try
to complicate the position and i always
try to move as near to my opponent's
king as i can
and uh i could dive into this one next
the black pawn
and if you take the rook at least do
some damage to your king and i think it
was you david who mentioned this this
check you've also got the capture of the
pawn in front of the white king so just
try and complicate the position uh while
i get a chance and and make a little bit
of chaos because the pawn structure is
bad i i want to create some weaknesses
around the white king side as well and
at least this this idea does that yeah
exactly there's plenty of ideas here for
both sides and it's not clear whose king
is weaker actually in a position like
this and you also mentioned this check
which looks maybe even stronger it was a
nasty move here though i just realized
you can go pawn takes and
i don't want to take that one back
suddenly a checkmate and we're talking
about the kings black's king gets
trapped first so um yeah magnus working
out all of these types of variations
okay he doesn't choose the move that you
mentioned i like that one
despite the fact it was still very messy
i like bringing the queen not just near
the white king but also to protect the
pawn in the center magnus instead
choosing a safe square but it will get
hit at some point white's knight is
going to gain time against this black
queen so a bit of a mysterious one there
by magnus carson and
what's his idea if white does take this
rook i mean white actually can just take
the knight that looks pretty good too
very very tempting but if you take the
rook
what does black have in store here if
you just recapture this bishop back then
in this position it's actually level
material but these black pawns are just
gonna be picked off one by one and white
is going to win
yeah so magnus needs something special
something magical and
the evaluation bar now has gone in
white's favor because maybe there isn't
anything now for black
so i was just going to ask take the
rogue or take the knight what's your
instinct
i mean
i like trying to keep the initiative and
i i would probably um well okay
obviously the the players
they just go uh lev moving his knight in
to attack the queen i didn't like so
much because it's maybe possible to kind
of now flick in this check yeah yeah why
not
and uh pawn takes knight could maybe be
met by queen takes born
it looks very dangerous out there ivanka
because the one idea i think magnus had
about putting his queen on a light
square is that the black queen points
towards that little guy over around
black's king and i think he's going for
this now so this is uh is this turning
around in magnus's favor possibly yeah
and look at the computer evaluation
there it did say that this last move by
black bringing the knight to this square
was actually the only way to maintain
the balance but it also does give black
the advantage and now if we see the
computer suggestions after this night
check no matter what white does black
has an advantage i mean the most obvious
move is also the best move here
according to stockfish according to the
computer that's taking this knight that
will happen i'm pretty sure and now
black most likely is going to jump in
with his queen and capture a pawn i mean
even that is not forced i mean there are
options here you could even just take
this pawn with your own pawn and hit the
white queen
for example if the white queen
recaptures you can actually save both
your queen and the rook at the same time
by lifting your queen up and offering a
trade
so
suddenly levon aronian lost control
maybe just trying to be a bit too clever
by bringing his knight in earlier when
he could have just taken the black rook
or taking the black knight both
seemingly with an advantage yeah it's
probably that that position you said
earlier where you have too many good
moves uh you have a choice of two good
moves taking the night taking the rook
and you play the third move
and you get a bit confused you know i i
remember one thing that the britain's
first ever grand master tony miles said
and i i didn't hear this myself but it
was quite famous that tony miles
his sort of catchphrase was always play
the simple moves there's nothing wrong
with the simple moves so if there's a
good simple option why over complicate
it if you can get an advantage by
playing something very easy then play
that move you don't need to go into
complications so that might have been
something which lev could uh certainly
regret here i feel yeah yeah so he would
definitely regret not taking this rook
meanwhile after the night jump after the
night check it has been captured and as
i mentioned this is also an option pawn
takes pawn hitting the white queen and
levon aronian is the master of counter
attack but here magnus is doing that
he's just leaving his own queen but now
the white queen is the one under fire
this is a crazy crazy position and it
all comes down to that sin that i
mentioned actually earlier in that
advert thinking levon overthought the
position
and now he's lost control the queen's
about to disappear as well black's queen
has been captured by the white knight
and magnus will take the white queen off
and according to ty stats with a win for
magnus he's going to be qualified for
the knockouts 100
and levono will be down to 20 chance to
qualify he really has to avoid a loss
here a draw will have live on 35 percent
chance to qualify a win we'll have him
at 73 chance to qualify is this a game
right now where anything can happen any
results still possible yep definitely
there's still sufficient materials i
mean there's plenty of pawns on the
board as well so anything could happen
but i did notice levon aronian slightly
shake his head a few moments ago he
knows he's lost control of this one and
it does feel like if magnus is accurate
he can break out now also look at that
black pawn it's one square away from
promotion it is covered by the white
rook at the moment but there will be
tricks concerning that pawn and it it
will take white a few moves to go and
round it up to pick it off and level
around look at it
he's gesturing he's not happy at all
okay poke her face back but uh for sure
uh magnus will be happy and here he has
choice he can capture the white knight
that makes sense but it is also tempting
to capture the white bishop instead
black's king what do we think guys which
piece is it going to take
i mean in this position i quite like the
black bishop if you
just just take the bishop so
because then we might better free our
dark square bishop by playing some pawn
break later on and get that into the
game and also you don't want to lose
black's pawn on the side of the board on
a5 so i'd probably just go king takes
bishop with the idea of some pawn break
yeah and i think ivanka like blacks
blacks also well blacks are porn up at
the moment so uh it is certainly turned
around in magda's favor and this is what
you see in chess and it's such a hard
game you can play very nicely some
lovely ideas one little mistake and you
lose the game especially at this level
um it's it's such high class that's uh
that's what makes chess is exciting
though but i i agree with you that um
simon i think i would just take the
bishop and then
do a pawn break and i'm primarily
thinking of the
sea pawn
move it up one square because if that
bishop gets released then goodness knows
it's going to wreak
terrible terrible danger but you know
chess is chess
and
i love that about chess that one move
besides the outcome i don't think
there's any other sport or game don't
really compare because you can think
about golf you make a bad shot you can
get back into i can't think of anything
else where one bad move can just ruin
your whole tournament one little moment
out of like let's say three days four
days of playing chess so it's really
quite unique in in the stress levels uh
i i you know i'd be interesting to hear
if anyone at home can think of anything
that compares to that i mean on the top
of my head i
myself you can never really rest in
chess
basically you have to be 100 focused all
the time right and
well it keeps us all excited and talking
about excited people well we do have
some selfies and nadia asman says it's
1am in malaysia
and it's a great palindrome 2202 2015.
she's got a birthday and capping the day
off she's rooting for cassanic to score
for the ladies and i have to admit yeah
that would be very nice and uh also we
have tom james who is watching levon
against magnus
and uh says it's exciting stuff yeah
definitely and that palindrome so 2002
2022
it's the same
backwards forwards and upside down even
i heard yeah my my nephew actually um it
was a bit worrying because when he was
born
he was his due date was the sixth of the
sixth
and he missed it by two days
we called him damian anyway um but no no
no
no we didn't we didn't call him damien
but he was due to be born on the sixth
six and six like no so uh but um yeah
it's a very strange date isn't it
absolutely and chess player loves those
uh coincidences and you know i think
magnus even tweeted about it himself
about the date yeah so chess plays they
love those patterns and
meanwhile we do have an answer to the
age-old question knights or bishops
every world champion seems to favor a
different one but magnus did take off
the bishop and the white bishop instead
of the white knight so you guys were
right
and now it is bishop versus knight that
means magnus will try and open up the
position open up diagonals for his minor
piece the white knight has to retreat
here has to run away
does that tell us something about his
style that he does prefer prefer uh the
bishops definitely um and often he
prefers positions where he has the
bishops as a pair but in this type of
position which will quite likely explode
thanks to pawn breaks like ivanka
mentioned pushing pawns forward maybe
trying to get rid of white stronghold
that strong white pawn in the center
and once that does happen the black
bishop is likely to be superior to its
counterpart so
this maybe it's about the specifics of
this position but in general i think
magnus prefers his bishops if we rewind
his predecessor and and preferred
knights
can i just say david so we're seeing
some moves there i was wondering after
this knight c5 magnus played the very
obvious e5 there's also moving the
bishop trying to get it to support the
pawn bishop h6 which was
a move but okay the way he's played it
seems very good as well doesn't it just
opening up the bishop there in the
middle of the board yeah so uh just to
show um your idea simon so the white
knight did retreat to a nice outpost and
magnus did try and explode open the
center this was the first move that came
to my mind but a sneaky one would have
been to bring the bishop to the side and
try to bring it in to support the
promotion of the white pawn this would
pretty much force i guess the white rook
to come across like bishop could now
dive in and capture a pawn
black is still a pawn up but
maybe magnus just thought he wanted to
be more direct here
trying to find a move for white right
now maybe the rook could come across hit
this bishop and if bishop takes pawn
maybe the white knight could start
dancing
with a check with a fork
personally i think this is very good for
black as well and maybe magnus missing a
trick there but uh the move he played
pushing this pawn forward also very
logical and after this trade maybe he'll
go for the same idea but he could also
think about activating his rook maybe
this is magnus's plan to try and bring
his rook into the game now
all right well it's a dramatic day you
guys eight players will leave us after
today and look at the bars in the bottom
of the screen in the other games that
just left us but i did notice one game
eric hansen the bar all the way over to
his side in his game against the
underponyachi moves are coming out
thinking fast here yeah very quick moves
in such a complicated end game so pieces
have disappeared but black is still one
porn up and uh i'm just surprised that
magnus has moved that quickly i thought
there were plenty of other tempting
options at his disposal but he's running
with the king now and this does allow
for example the white rook to come up
with a check but that would run into
black's king walking even further down
the board hitting a couple of pieces
black's king is going to act as a very
uh very strong piece in this end game
it's easier to get the black king to the
center it's actually very easy for black
to centralize his rook as well and being
a porn up in an end game like this one
should give a decisive advantage um
especially if the rooks come off with
pawns on both sides of the board bishops
are better than knights so lebron
ironian needs to maybe keep the rooks on
and be a bit tricky with his knight as
simon mentioned earlier nights are
tricky so magnus can't relax yet
and black's bishop there was on the fire
so it does retreat
all right well as mentioned it's looking
really really good for eric hansen
number 237 in the world with a win in
this game
wow he's going to be super close too
qualification
if not even 100 sure
that is uh
wow we will keep an eye on that game
liam looking good for him against
kostanyuk or tamiya the bar over to his
side in his game against niman
and what else anish giri the bar also
over to his side against mamjar of geary
is also not
by any means safe to qualify so a win
would be great news for him
action everywhere and i did just take a
quick peek over at the other game hanson
against nepalishi and it's not just that
he has an advantage but it's also a
long-term advantage so unless there's a
big blunder he should be winning that
game against the tournament leader and
what a result that would be oh no
because that guy said that you know they
kind of wrote this game off so any
result that uh you know eric was able to
get from that game was a massive bonus
on his way to qualifying so that's
that's really good news for the chess
bra fans out there yeah um yeah
there's a bunch of them the chess bra
fans wow and uh it's gonna be
interesting to see if he qualifies who
he will face also in the course finals
starting tomorrow all right what's
happening okay so white's night trying
to get a bit tricky there's simply
nothing else to do you have to try and
get some of those black pawns with your
knight but magnus did fend off an attack
from the night by just stepping a pawn
forward and white's knight has had to
retreat and
that last retreat it's a sad move to
play that is almost an admission of
defeat white's knight now not on a great
circuit can't jump forward anywhere
effective and black's rook has entered
the action so white's king now stepping
forward that shows that levon really
doesn't have any active plans and now
it's just down to magnus to activate the
black king maybe start pushing some
pawns forward and
it should be a matter of time magnus in
top form i think would win this every uh
i think he'd win this ten out of ten
yeah but uh
level iranian maybe just knowing that
his opponent's still suffering from the
effects of covert maybe still some
practical chances what do you think
i don't know i don't think so because
i'm looking at white's rook to see
whether that can be a nuisance and uh
it's dominated by the dark squared
bishop and as long as the black rook has
control over the eighth rank there's
just no way that the white rook is going
to get
involved into the game
unless magnus takes the decision to
allow it
yeah maybe white's only chance is to
move the rook down to try and attack the
the pawn uh on the f file um we're
talking about people playing uh on you
know i was gonna say under the influence
um probably not the right term under the
covert influence and um i remember
actually it's quite interesting that um
england number one for many many years
mickey adams uh actually said that he
played better when he had a cold or a
flu because he
yeah actually played more natural it's
like i know some people say they play
better on a hangover because they don't
think they just play they play without
thinking and they let their kind of
subconscious uh take over their moves
which is uh an interesting way look at
it but i think it certainly didn't
recover it has different effects to like
you know your traditional cold so um
yeah
yeah i actually found the same when i
was younger at least i've i always
played better when
uh when i had a cold when i was uh i may
be about to be ill just because you
there's nothing else you can do you have
to sit at the board you have to focus um
you don't have the energy to get up and
walk around and be distracted but the
older i get the more i feel the effects
i think i would be struggling too if i
were in magnus's shoes um
not feeling 100 physically fit yeah at
least he's got an easy position to play
uh this is just the kind of thing he'd
want he doesn't really have to think
here i mean you know you only have to
think a couple of moves ahead in
positions like this and just know where
to move your pieces and pawns and
he's doing well he knows he knows what
he's doing here doesn't he's going to
win this i think it does feel that way
and yeah normally the
disasters that does that do happen to
magnus they come when the queens are on
the board when there's complications
when there's stuff to calculate here as
you mentioned simon not much to
calculate i think the only thing you
need to see here as black is that if
white's rook does come up to the sixth
rank which it does targeting a lot of
pawns the black can now challenge that
rook with his own rook and offer the
trade and as we mentioned any rook
exchanges black is just going to win uh
black's bishop will
be more flexible than the knight with
pawns on both sides and black's king is
ready to make a dart towards white pawns
on this side of the board so
no rook trade possible for white and
magnus just doing magnus things
advancing slowly with pawns on the side
he's stronger black has a three versus
two advantage on this right side so why
not play that yeah and one idea that i
saw for magnus but way ahead in the
future is actually just to push annie
the a pawn one square forward and you
know try to clear the path for the
seaport just to i thought it was alice
alice
come on get it right
it's harry's brother harry
what are you doing
butchering the pawns here
can't blimey
tour director arnold
there's been big controversy about that
name there has oh yes oh yes there's
been even a whole art a day
because there's apparently uh
in norway more top leaders by the name
of arna than there are female top
leaders which is not good
oh dear yeah
anyway
but here we're 50 50.
two girls two men usually you're you're
outnumbered usually david
simon
i'm doing a few days forming a team now
yeah um but on that note gary the g pawn
has just pushed forward offering a trade
but
white now
here's simon would you trade off a set
of pawns here would you keep harry on
the board i think you're right
i think you've got to complicate it here
the more the more you play into your
opponent's hands the more you make it i
mean normally when you're trying to draw
a position you want to make exchanges
because you were with the pawns you want
to get rid of the pawns but what i was
thinking they push harry on on one
square on to at least give him the
chance of getting blacks harry porn a
lot of harry's going on in the moment um
this check i'm not really sure what it
achieves
and i think it's also quite notable that
uh one thing i was taught when i was
younger that when you're playing with
the bishop against the knight especially
in an ending a strategy you should try
to use which magnus has done with his g
pawn the gary pawn is to try and
restrict your opponent's knight with
your pawns so you slowly move your pawns
forwards to restrict your opponent's
knight and then you try to push that
knight backwards and make your opponents
night worse and worse and i i think
that's the general thing that obviously
uh black is is trying to achieve here i
i don't really get this check um to be
honest so i'm not not sure what what's
happening here how how how does that
actually help lev is he is he going to
go after harry now maybe possibly that
must be the only idea he can go after
harry because if he does then you kind
of mentioned the white knight being
restrained doesn't have too many squares
so you can just simply attack it with a
pawn and uh pour all night gonna go to
the corner
ah it's not pretty over there i mean i
guess you have to do this so yeah so i
mean
this is gonna happen i think uh okay
white's idea is to attack this pawn and
this pawn at the same time but now black
can defend them both with a simple pawn
move pushing this pawn forward guarding
its fellow here but also protecting with
his rook and this has actually happened
in the uh in the position and now
white's rook coming across to attack is
it freddie uh freddie the f-born
yeah right now dave black's rook black's
rook is a bit overstretched it does want
to defend this pawn in the corner but
now it struggles to defend this pawn as
well for example if it steps up one
square uh which it does uh level ronin
he's doing a chase so first he gives a
check and no matter where the black king
goes i think he's going to try and bring
his rook to start chasing these black
pawns white tonight is terribly placed
for now um but at least he's complicated
the white knight now coming back into
the game this is this is actually uh has
a very nice route yeah it's a very
sneaky move because the whole idea
actually is that now the white rook can
attack the pawn and it's controlling a
few critical squares for the from the
bishop i'm not convinced actually that
magnus's uh
maybe this check which i thought was bad
was a very clever idea by lev i mean
this night it might just win that if
porn now how did you stop this idea yeah
the night it's destined to jump forward
right at some point you have to and this
pawn is doomed
maybe it's going to become a race okay
he first pushes his h born forward there
will be a race in the position i was
going to say if the black rook comes
down white's rook takes the spawn
defending an important pawn here but
after rook takes pawn i don't know who's
going to be quicker it feels like maybe
this black born is going to win the game
after black picks off this guy this guy
here so that is why levon and ronin
pushed harry forward we're going to see
a race maybe between harry and alice
this
side and also the time situation is
getting very low and i think uh somehow
aronian has kind of given himself some
chances and this is a great practical
way of playing that if you play normal
moves you're going to get in trouble so
he's found a way to complicate the
position and i think as we said like
tony miles keep things simple if you've
got an easy way but if you if you've got
a bad position you should nearly always
try to complicate which uh at least lev
has has achieved here
in the position yep and suddenly it's
not clear what black can do black wants
to bring his rook down and attack some
pawns but at the moment white tonight is
doing a great job of covering any entry
squares so right now black is a bit
stuck and white has a clear plan either
of picking off this guy or picking off
the f pawn instead
and yep it's going to be a pawn race no
matter what and despite the computer
saying 0.0 again that's so frustrating i
think this one could go either way a
decisive result is still very likely in
this one and eric hansen he has won the
game against tournament leader janna
pognatchi bringing him to
22 points in third place currently eric
hansen i mean
i can't calculate that fast but he is he
must be very close to uh qualified for
the knockout stage incredible by the
canadian that is so much fun for chess
for chess fans i think tai said 23 is
the magic number where you nearly
guarantee your qualification for the
knockout so he might just be one point
away one draw in his final two games uh
would guarantee it but even if he loses
his last two games still decent chances
yeah
incredible and uh well magnus was
feeling uncomfortable with the situation
and that's why he's clarified matters
so he's going to say no no race instead
i'm giving back the pawn
and
i'm just going to try to outplay white
using the fact that my bishop is better
than the white knight actually i think
this is magnus just trying to escape the
game with the draw okay because the
pawns have just disappeared there aren't
sufficient pawns left and look at magnus
reacting there he did eliminate harry
simon you must be annoyed about that um
he went for a porn trade but he gave up
a pawn well he gave a pawn back in the
process and now if the rooks do
disappear
it does feel like black's gonna take too
long with the black king to go after
those white pawns it feels like
everything's just gonna get eliminated
white's knight can even give itself up
for some pawns later on and it should
just be a draw now this is one case
where the more pawns that get exchanged
the nearer to a draw you do get
um i know lev avoided this earlier but
uh in general you just want to get the
pawns off the board because you need a
pawn of the ending to queen and
that knight has some very nice squares i
mean it it it should be a draw magnus is
indicated from his body language as well
it's going that way i i mean i'm not
even sure what he missed to be honest i
don't think it was a major blunder i
think lev played fantastically well with
that move i did not expect to to
complicate
and give himself some chances so well
played lev yeah it was all about those
rook maneuvers earlier they looked
really intricate it wasn't clear the
idea behind them but there was always um
there was always a plan behind lebron's
moves and now very nice putting a pawn
on a light square white's king is
getting ready to step up the board
and meanwhile it's going to take black
still a long time to get those white
pawns on the left side yeah i do feel
that this game is going to edge towards
the draw but i do think that white has
to be incredibly accurate so for
instance now i mean i'm not quite sure i
understand why
love has allowed magnus to enter
with your king that's the problem
wherever you go with the black king
there'll be a night check there'll be a
night fork nights are so tricky and just
a fortress what is he going for right
it's pretty much a fortress black's
pawns are all they're all isolated as
well they're spread out and they are
easy targets for the white knight i
don't think black's in time to protect
all his pawns and get in with the black
king
um
even if you win one pawn in the process
it probably shouldn't be enough
white's king is running over to this
side now
and
okay there we go the march continues
again no matter where you bring the
black king if you go this way there's a
check in the center if you go the other
way there's a check with the white
knight
winning ambition this time around i
guess as well so
and uh yeah okay i mean lev's an amazing
in-game player as well i mean i know we
talk about how strong magnus is i mean i
guess everyone agree here that magnus is
the strongest of all time in the ending
there's no one who can get near him uh
in the ending but
looking at some of the lev's games as
well lev must be one of the best end
game players ever he's he's got so much
experience and that's something that age
helps you with uh i'm probably gonna
he's probably gonna lose now after i say
that but let's see
more pawns getting exchanged this this
is only helping the defender yeah and
now if black's king goes and takes the
white pawn next to it then white's
knight works you go to the edge of the
board with a check and that's a double
attack it will go back and capture
black's pawn on the c6 square so yeah
everything we're about to see that
happen everything getting traded this
one is just a dead draw now all right
then enough material left to checkmate
hopefully we're going to make it to the
ending of ding against jesse panko yep
it is a draw in this one um that is good
news for magnus carlsen levonian